on va passer avoue isabelle morini-bosc
avec la mise au point alors on va
revenir sur toute l'histoire parce que
il ya des chroniqueurs qui voulait
réagir le public aussi hier ma chérie
vous avez fait une petite mise au point
concernant la polémique sur mesnel la
candidate de the voice qui s'est
exprimée encore ce soir sur intel
apparemment elle va être sorti un par
tf1 suite à ses tweets mesnel vous avez
l'info isabelle un médecin qui est tf1
tout à l'heure sur rtl on a dit que tf1
n'avait pas encore pris de décision
ferme de lyon effet voilà alors depuis
ces faits elle est sortie c'est sur moi
je sais pas non adacore ben merci en
tout cas d'être là tf1 je suis là faire
de très près a priori moi je pense
d'après nos infos je pense qu'elle va
être de sortie de deux vols suite à ces
tweets à polémique et isabelle vous êtes
exprimé sur la petite polémique créée
autour de vous et il ya des chroniqueurs
qui voulait réagir il soit on va voir
l'extrait et je crois qu'il ya gâteau
proulx qui voudraient agir même sur
l'ensemble des chroniqueurs et sur vous
vous avez un coup de coeur un coup de
gueule contre vous en faites pareil
contre moi mais moi je vois vous même
débat n'hésitez pas à les scanner toute
la dette par garde était en deux temps
d'abord il fallait très vite en direct
dans un temps tripale j'adore cette
chanson j'aime pas qu'on la touche
j'aime quand la chambre telle qualité et
le deuxième temps effectivement il ya le
contexte de cette jeune femme et donc du
coup il ya tout un ensemble qui moi m'a
semblé ambiguë mais ça ne va pas vous de
la fois pas louer racisme là dedans
votre frappe elle était voilà oui on
peut on peut comprendre l orée de
développer ceux qui ont été choqués et
qu'on demandait des explications
je les en remercie parce que moi je suis
quelqu'un de nuancer si on me demande
une explication je la donne et si on me
dit il faut que tu t'expliques plus j'en
suis tout à fait d'accord c'est mon
boulot à m
alors regardez si vous avez été
convaincante
isabelle sur cette polémique rona un
sondage plutôt oui à 56 pour son nom à
44% et vous agathe vous venez sur ce
qu'avait dit isabelle avait dit voilà et
vous vous êtes vous êtes énervé contre
vous en faites non mais j'aimerais
revenir très sérieusement juste deux
secondes sur l'émission de lundi soir
moi je regrette amèrement la séquence
qu'on a tous fait ici sur sur ce cas
lundi soir en direct dans l'émission je
regrette de ne pas avoir eu le courage
d'avoir un contre-discours et d'apporter
une opinion contraire à tout ce qui
s'est dit sur le plateau parce qu'on
allait tous dans le même
ce qui était de taper sur cette gamine
alors qu'il ne connaissait absolument
rien de ce qui s'était passé et je
trouve que on à raconter des inepties
inepties sur inepties dont contre l'
amalgame d'isabelle qui n'a pas été
compris entre benjamin castaldi excuse
moi qui relaie des faits que nous la
fachosphère en parlant d' apologie au
terrorisme ou en traitant des proxys en
prêtant si en prêtant une proximité
tu va retirer tout de suite en prêtant
longue date au dessus et je plaisante
pas là entraîneur je présente pas tu
aurais fait à tout de suite
malheureusement c'est les sources
benjamin mois internet fashion alors
j'ai maintenant faut pas déconner non
mais j'ose faire de quoi c'est la
fachosphère tiens voilà là vous allez
loin rôle est rien du tout on fait la
somme péter hammill dur au rire c'est à
une peine de prison de sept ans et 100
mille euros d'amendé dirait que ça c'est
des biens le terrorisme c'est bien en
aucun cas c'est ce qu'elle a dit en
aucun cas elle ne la souhaitait et la
fachosphère donc que benjamin n'a jamais
relayé à prêter à cette jeune fille une
proximité avec des groupes extrémistes
ce qui n'est absolument pas le cas
comment vous savez que ce vol fasse
appel a été vérifiée ça a été vérifiée
ou ça a été vérifiée alors à gâteau
proulx il ya un instant vous avez vous
avez vous avez dit votre sentiment sur
ce qu'avait dit isabelle morini bosc
il ya deux jours dans tpm paix au sujet
des tweets de cette jeune fille de the
voice
voilà qui a qui a eu quatre huit caf qui
a eu des tweets très très maladroit on
va dire si ce n'est plus et vous devez
dès que ici en chroniqueur et même vous
même vous mais vous mettez dedans avait
dit est un tissu de conneries mais j'ai
pas compris alors à laisser terminer
parce qu'à plein de jolies bulles ne l'a
pas laissée éminemment si j'étais blessé
alors rien nous te prêter aucune rien du
tout pas mort c'est bon passer à autre
chose
non mais benjamin alors non pas
l'ensemble est là pour discuter sans
méchant dit jamais non mais je vous le
disais alors non mais juste c'est pas
parce que on passe deux heures à la télé
tous les soirs en direct qu'on peut se
transformer en tribunal public on ait
personne pour dire ce qui regarde notre
avait jeté une opération lancée mais la
question c'est est-ce qu'elle doit être
viré ou non je pense qu'on ait personne
pour dire qu'il allait
alors non mais alors non mais alors
agathe l'avons mis en cause notre avis
sur tout c'est le projet d'émission vous
disent que vous vous énervez pour rien
je remets jury en cause une séquence
dans l'émission je remets pas en cause
les missions que j'adore à laquelle je
participe avec plaisir c'est essentiel
est votre problème alors eh ben je pense
qu'on s'est trompé a participé au
lynchage médiatique de cette gamine et
7,8 soit insupportable a réveillé je
pense qu'on peut faire preuve de plus de
tolérance ici de donner ça c'est
pourquoi la manche je suis désolé mais
moi je regarde ça avec avec les victimes
qui a eu déjà quant à moi je pense
qu'ils aient un minimum de pudeur et et
franchement il est vrai terrorisme à
gouverner moi à moi quand je pense à
tous les gens et toutes les familles des
des coups d'oeil ça et qui la voit
chanter dans the voice après je suis
désolé moi ça passe pas a garanti la
vérité voilà ça passe là voici voilà il
ya plein de gens et toute la france a
été touchée par ces attentats
j'ai passé s'est passé ici en un seul
film et ça même si on peut croire
c'était quand elle était jeune c'était
c'était ça passe pas je suis désolé moi
voilà je vous le dis c'est pas des
événements très graves
et ici on est là pour divertir dans
cette émission
mais là où on est là aussi pour dire les
choses et a plein de jeunes je les dis
dans l'ariège l'instant qui nous regarde
et il ya plein de gens qui ont été très
choqués il ya des familles des victimes
qui peut-être nous regardent ce soir
et quand ils voient cette jeune fille
chanter et qui voit dans ce vol s'ils
ont envie de se détendre il voit les
tweets derrière je dis non alors on
n'est pas là pour jouer on a donné notre
avis il est juste pas d'accord moi je
trouve pour se transformer en un
tribunal public samaté plus gelé
exprimer ici je conçois pas d'accord
c'est assez simple oui je sais bien
qu'on sait pas ce que j'ai fait ce que
j'avais soit vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec le fait de oui elle doit être viré
oui c'est mal ce qu'elle a fait et où il
faut la virer jeu qu'on a et on lui trop
mais c'est moi samassa match ça m'a
déplu pour sois pas d'accord et je sois
la sias pas que c'était entre vous c'est
parce que je trouve bien dans son coup
de gueule à agathe c'est que 10 où je me
suis trompé j'ai réussira pas trouvé
bien et tout ça je trouve ça très bien
par contre quand tu dis on a tous dit
une connerie l'atuge tout le monde est
là je crois que tu te dépasse un peu les
banques parce que moi personnellement je
sais très bien ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit
qu'on devait être responsable de ces
tweets et je le maintiens c'est pas des
scuds la jeunesse - n'est pas valable et
c'est très bien et donc pour moi dire
d'un seul coup chacun dit ce qu'il veut
et ce n'est pas un tribunal je pense que
de toute façon on fait des
des procès beaucoup trop vite sur les
réseaux sociaux on va pas les faire ici
c'est une chacun à exprimer une opinion
un sentiment mais en aucun cas on veut
du mal à cette jeune fille on la
connaissait pas samedi on la trouvait
tous formidables d'addition je suis très
douée sa chanson était formidable en
langue arabe elle était très très belle
très belle audio nice il ya une
polémique sur le voile à un moment on a
pris position nous mais nous on l'a dit
voilà nous on a aujourd'hui au contraire
des gens voilà la dérision des gens avec
des kippas on l'a toujours dit on est
ouvert à à ce que tout le monde fasse de
la télévision parce qu'il ya eu la
polémique là-dessus sur ça on s'est
insurgé que tout soit la polémique
qu'avait eue sur cette jeune fille parce
que voilà elle elle portait voilà le
voilà prêt j'ai voulu vendre mais le
truc mais sur ces tweets là moi je peux
pas je peux vraiment pas l'excusé agathe
est ici on donnait juste ravi après
c'est le principe de l'émission et ses
pardons mais ça devrait être la vie de
tous les français non bagis enfin un
tweet qui fait pardon mais au vu de ce
que je me vois j'ai pas suivi d'affaires
donc mais à mon tour je vais me
permettre d'ouvrir ma gueule sans
exemple me regarde pas mais je vois pas
en quoi ça c'est pas condamnable c'est
tout à fait condamnable et en tant que
français et moi mon pays je dis que ce
tweet là n'a rien à faire là et que
cette femme n'a rien à faire dans une
émission de télévision
je vois pas en quoi c'est en train de la
faire passer pour une victime même en
question les victimes des attentats elle
le dit elle dit alors je voulais pour la
elle dit juste aussi qu'on a été on l'a
jugé trop vite c'est de toute façon nous
ont juste des faits par l'ancien mais ça
nous donnait beaucoup de pouvoir est-ce
qu'on aurait pouvoir devenir quelqu'un
pas du tout j'aimais on a juste et primé
d exprimer des opinions et après de
toute façon le nez ce qui doit faire le
boulot c'est la production et tf1 qui
doivent mener une enquête sérieuse parce
que je suis d'accord il faut pas se
précipiter faut vérifier si tous ces
accusations proférées vérifier ou pas si
c'est s'exprimer ce soir sur arte l on
va l'écouter mais écoutez j'ai vraiment
conscience que ce que j'ai écrit
c'était vraiment des bêtises tu es
serait mal écrit d'ailleurs et j'avais
20 ans à l'époque et je tiens à
m'excuser auprès des familles des
victimes d'avoir heurter leur
sensibilité de les avoir blessé
en aucun cas je ne tolère ce qui s'est
passé c'est vrai que si la chaîne elle
décide de m'évincer du jeu je serais
déçu parce que je n'aurais pas eu
l'occasion de montrer qui je suis
vraiment et surtout que je ne suis pas
celle que l'on dépeint dans les médias
et dans les réseaux alors elle est très
gentil c'est une fille mais c'est que
mon dépeint dans les réseaux et dans les
médias nous on est on est et où on
trouvait qu'elle invente alain
formidable les téléspectateurs aussi
c'est juste qu'on se fout se base sur
les tweets qu'elle a fait et gilles
verdez elle tente une opération de
réhabilitation avec d'autres personnes
qui la soutiennent et moi je suis très
en colère contre agathe je vais très
calme mais parce que agathe cède et
devient faible parce que comme moi
quelques personnes y ont dit mais
pourquoi vous avez lyncher critique et
demandé qu'elle soit viré moi aussi j'ai
eu des gens qui m'ont dit mais pourquoi
parce que effectivement parce que l
fracturé la société française avec ce
qu'elle dit parce que c'est inacceptable
parce qu'on peut pas écrire que les
vrais terroristes gouvernement parce que
sinon tout est permis parce que sinon
c'est la france qui ne va plus se
retrouver en elle-même donc je je je
sais que pour elle c'est difficile parce
que son rêve se brise
mais il fallait penser avant au nom de
la france on peut pas laisser passer ça
si on la maintient dans l'émission c'est
encore une fois humilié l'association
des victimes des attentats de nice qui
demande aussi son exclusion et qui
compte
agathe bien plus que moi vient plus que
nous tous parce qu'ils ont souffert au
nom de tout symbole il faut virer mes
mails de the voice
voilà
[Applaudissements]
série alors l'excusent rescue de la
jeunesse n'est pas bon c'était en 2016
où elle a fait ses ses tweets la wiimote
et en 2018 quand même un monsieur moi je
veux agathe udrih vous laisse le mot de
la fin qu'est ce que vous dites est ce
que tout ce qui s'est dit là autour de
la table mais moi je dis que j'entends
tout le monde que évidemment je ne
cautionne pas les tweets et que je suis
là peut-être la mieux placée pour savoir
ce qu'est un lynchage médiatique et je
moi je regrettais alors je ne parle plus
au nom de qui que ce soit ici mais
seulement en le mien et je regrettais
dit avoir d'avoir pu y participer en
ayant des propos beaucoup trop
vindicatifs et en jugeant peut-être
beaucoup trop rapidement quelque chose
que je ne maîtrisais pas c'est tout
d'accord c'est en fait c'est ça que vous
reprochez c'est qu'on vous pensez qu'il
fallait attendre un petit peu pour avoir
plus d'explications ont jugé cette jeune
fille je pense qu'il fallait pas elle
elle était déjà victime d'un lynchage
par des victimes je peux vous poser
toutes les questions à gaza on sait que
vous avez eu des problèmes on va lire
sur twitter aussi parce que vous avez
fait des tweeds de vannes ce que vous
aviez dit il ya quelques années
est ce que c'est pour ça aussi c'est
votre expérience perso vous avez été
victime vraiment d'un teen lynchage sur
les réseaux sociaux qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui vous dit j'ai envie de
défendre voilà et des personnes et un
siège aux jeux c'est le seuil est
essentielle quelle peut être la
dangerosité de cette relation
d'immédiateté qu'on a avec le avec le
média avec les réponses avec le dialogue
je sais qu'elle peut être la dangerosité
de deux mots prononcés à chaud je sais
qu'elle peut être la dangerosité d'un
débat beaucoup trop où le camp quand
toutes les comptes ou les paramètres ne
sont pas maîtrisés effectivement moi ça
m'est arrivé et on m'a reproché des
mauvaises blagues effectivement que j'ai
fait entre 2011 et 2013 sur sur mes
potes qui faisait le ramadan et qui ne
m'ont pas aidé à mettet ménagers ou sur
le chômage en france je sais plus trop
quoi
enfin bref donc là mais ça c'est les
blagues aussi qu'on cautionne pas ici
mais je veux redire ici évidemment et je
vous le dis moi toutes les personnes qui
sont ici sont racistes non
[Rires]
vous le savez non mais vous savez on m'a
même reproché vraiment de deux mètres de
mettre des gens à l'antenne avec des
kippas et wallons moi je suis l'homme
vraiment ici je veux que les jurés ont
du coeur soit les plus ouverts c'est la
mode
non mais voilà c'est la france ici ça
représente la france tout le monde a le
droit de donner son avis je vous le dis
nous ici on n'est pas des donneurs de
leçons on dit pas il faut aller voir tel
spectacle
il faut faire telle chose il faut voter
pour tel ou tel personne même des
personnes je vous le dis voilà qui
peuvent voter pour des gens voient la
casse pour lesquelles je ne voterai
jamais il faut essayer de savoir
pourquoi et les vraies raisons pour
lesquelles ces personnes votent power
pour tel ou tel parti
donc ici on donnera jamais le sont
faites ce que vous voulez juste toutes
les opinions sont les bienvenus et ici
on pense que le débat et les changes et
ben peuvent peut-être faire avancer les
choses et peut-être faire changer d'avis
telle ou telle personne agathe moi je
trouve voilà j'espère que vraiment et je
vous le dis sur twitter sur les réseaux
sociaux ne vous en prenez pas garde
parce que moi je veux des gens qui
donnent leur avis voilà et je voudrais
d'ailleurs avoir benjamin castaldi votre
réponse agathe moi je trouve que voilà
c'est parti un peu vite
elle a surtout ça ne l'est pas te
blesser ou te tais tu as aussi à quoi
que ce soit mais je comprends activement
et c'est vrai que bon je comprends ton
point de vue mais dans ce cas précis
malheureusement ce que ton argumentation
ne me convient pas parce que quoi qu'on
dise quoi qu'on fasse ce qui a été écrit
il ya quand même juste un an et demi on
regarde ce qui s'est passé en france et
paca et paca nice on va pas rappeler
tout s'est passé ça n'est pas tolérable
en france quelqu'un tweets les
terroristes devant moi je ne gère pas ça
c'est pas possible pour moi mais il ya
même pas de discussions
cette personne a fait un tweet qui est
inacceptable et cette personne doit
dégager de 2 volts et le plus vite
possible
voilà non mais c'est surtout que tout ça
serve d'expérience à tout le monde c'est
à dire une qu'on vous pose c'est quelque
chose sur le réseau social panne d'un ça
reste vous exprimez votre opinion vous
voulez la partager avec des gens après
il faut l'assumer c'est ça qui est
difficile
et tu l'as vécu donc j'ai exactement ce
qui peut arriver après donc il vaut
moins que ça sert à tout ceux qui sont
là parce que encore aujourd'hui là tous
les soirs il ya un déversoir de haine
sur les réseaux sociaux
pas de souci par contre sera peut-être
un jour faut pas insulter l'avenir et
fera peut-être répondre de tout ça alors
un veau en tout cas vous êtes passé à
travers les gouttes ou parler
c'est bien les chéris débats polémiques
à gâteau proulx bavay c'est bien
possible mais en tout cas ici on est
ouvert au dialogue
sachez le et tout le monde peut
s'exprimer et c'est votre ssq est
magnifique c'est tennis alors voudrais
juste dire galiane watts qui doit
rentrer et là on va continuer parce que
yann moix que c'est un sujet vous avez
vu c'est ça qu'on aime ne touche pas à
mon poste et que toutes les émissions ne
se ressemblent pas et ben non mais là on
passe d'un mec qui paye et c'est ça
qu'on aime dans l'émission les chefs
et il a des choses à nous dire
et ce qui va vous montrer yann moix je
veux vraiment avoir votre avis dessus
également vous allez voir on va revenir
aussi sur tout ce qu'a dit yann moix
n'assureront pas risquer que sur calais
ce soir je poserai une seule question à
yann moix après sûr on n'est pas couché
mais une seule question oui moi je
voulais juste dire un truc agathe me
comprendre parce qu'elle a bossé aux
inrocks
quant à moi l'accusateur accusé de
racisme par exemple l'île une télé star
autrefois quand on lisait un truc comme
ça on regardait la vie de la personne en
faisant une vraie enquête pour voir s'il
était justifié mais non accusations vos
preuves a coûté voici donc allé assister
là dessus effectivement sans bras et les
réseaux sociaux qui ne vérifie rien et
qui agite par les communautés qui vous
montrent du doigt se trouve ça
franchement dégueulasse mais quel que
soit le cas de figure
et si c'est demain sur agathe cessera
dégueulasse et s'est passé c'est un truc
que je trouve épouvantable faire du clic
allez merci mont isa